the media's propaganda on behalf of
terrorist group Hamas continues
Democrats struggle in the polls and
North Korea tries to pull the rug out
from under President Trump I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
so a lot going on today we'll get to all
of it first I missed it yesterday we
made a pretty big announcement this
August I am taking the Ben Shapiro show
live to audiences in Dallas and Phoenix
and you'll be able to see me in person
and join in an audience Q&A we're also
doing a special VIP event beforehand
with assigning and meet-and-greet for
200 superfans I know the tickets are
really running out quickly they may
already be sold out actually so go check
it out right now
daily wear premium subscribers actually
have until tomorrow Thursday May 17th at
10:00 p.m. local time to get your
presale tickets so you have to do it
like right now because these things are
going super fast they may be gone and
Dallas already after that seats are
gonna go fast for general admission and
VIP access if you aren't a subscriber
this is the best time to do it once
again and go to daily wired.com slash
events to get your presale tickets an
additional info that's daily wire.com
slash events again those VIP tickets
mean you come backstage and we all hang
out and we talk and you get to take
pictures and get some swag it's pretty
awesome so daily wired.com slash events
become a member and you can get your
presale tickets now if you're just a
member of the general population then
wait for a day and a half and and then
you'll be able to get tickets as well
okay so I'm also I promise I'm gonna get
to the news in just one second before I
get to the news I also want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Zeile so you
may have found this week's news rather
disquieting somewhat upsetting maybe you
found it a little bit non relaxing well
this is why you need Zeile so Zeile is
one of these things that makes you feel
wealthy even when you are not for a
really reasonable price you can bring a
masseuse to your home and they bring the
spout with them they bring the table
they bring the massage oils they bring
the candles they bring the music they
bring the whole deal they come right to
you and it's on demand go to zeal comm
or seals iPhone or Android app that
Zeile spelled ze e Elcom then select
from top local licensed and pre-screened
massage therapists you can choose your
favorite technique gender preference
time and location for your massage and
they send one of their 10,000 licensed
massage therapists with all of the goods
scheduling booking payment fast and easy
even the tip is included 7 days a week
365 days a year
the Zeile massage therapist can be at
your door its privacy its convenience
its quality and its comfort it is
fantastic I have gotten zeal for my wife
have gotten informed my mother I've
gotten it for my father I've gotten it
for my in-laws I've gotten it for my
sister's it really is just first-rate so
check it out Zeile z ee l comm and when
you use promo code benin you actually
get 25 bucks off your first massage
again use that promo code been sealed
komm promo club and 25 bucks off your
first massage or use their zeal iPhone
or Android app and for that promo club
bed and get 25 bucks off that first
in-home massage use promo code Ben to
let them know that we sent you as well
okay so yesterday the media continued
their policy their policy is to repeat
whatever Hamas tells them the terrorist
group Hamas media coverage on this has
just been extraordinary and
demonstrative of the fact the media do
not care about the actual fact on the
ground in the slightest they
legitimately do not care about the facts
on the ground because I can show you
some of the facts on the ground we
showed you some of the facts on the
ground yesterday here are some more
facts on the ground so we begin with
this tweet okay this is from a reported
in BRAF Sanchez's from April so these
protests suppose it protests you know
peaceful protests that are actually
violent riots these have been going on
for two months these are actual pictures
from the Gaza Strip from Roz Sanchez
who's not a pro-israel reporter and he
tweeted out we met some young men
earlier cashing 200 dollar checks that
got from Hamas after being shot by
Israeli forces on Friday the severely
injured get 500 bucks the families of
the Dead get 3,000 bucks
so Hamas is paying people to go out
there and attempt to get shot by Israeli
forces so they can have those pictures
on the front pages of the newspapers
they're not being shy about any of this
Hamas is being absolutely clear about
their intents they're being 100%
transparent about what it is they wish
to do at least when they are talking to
their own people okay here's a
Palestinian man on NPR yesterday
explaining that their actual goal is to
break into Israel and kill as many Jews
as humanly possible the Israelis know
that people are flying kites with
swastikas they know this and they use it
to discredit you to say this shows
you're bad people what do you think
about that manna and a minimum how the
I mean fish about yeah must be
enough ago but enough so I said up the
ouya and this habit Liara this is
actually what we want them to know he
says that we want to burn them
it's the best part of that clip is power
Steve Inskeep is like you know they're
using your swastika for propaganda and
Hamas is like well I don't care we want
them to know that we want them to burn
in the ovens just like the Jews in the
Holocaust and I love the the puzzlement
of the media but but you don't
understand like it makes you guys look
bad like we don't care we want to kill
Jews and we like the swastika they're
they're earned there are no Jews by the
way living in the Gaza Strip it's
amazing for all the talk about apartheid
state zero Jews live in the Gaza Strip
zero Jews live in Palestinian Authority
controlled areas the reason is because
zero Jews live basically around the
Middle East all of these supposedly
moderate Muslim nations and leaders are
not interested in having Jews in their
country there is however in the Gaza
Strip a haircutting place called Hitler
I'm not kidding there's actually a shop
apparently called Hitler in the Gaza
Strip so they've got their priorities
very straight over there and again that
wouldn't when the media say that these
are nonviolent protests and that
everything is hunky-dory
okay this is coverage from yesterday
significant damage to farms inside
Israel due to these flight flow these
kite flown Molotov cocktails so here is
what's happening the the terrorists in
the Gaza Strip are making kites and then
they are putting Molotov cocktails which
essentially is alcohol or gasoline with
fire attached with little bombs and
they're flying them over the border and
then they are hoping that those kites
land in Israeli fields and start
significant fires and so you can see all
of the pictures online it's pretty
incredible they've made these large
kites they've attached Molotov cocktails
to them and you can see all the pictures
of the fields burning in Israel but
don't worry it's all nonviolent also
we've heard that Israel has been
indiscriminately shooting Palestinians
indiscriminately like just going out
there and mowing down Palestinians sure
there were 40,000 Palestinians who are
protesting who are rioting on the border
on Sunday and Monday sure only about 60
of them were killed and sure it turns
out that Hamas is admitting the vast
majority of those people were Hamas
members here is a senior official with
Hamas name is Salah al barred the wheel
and his on a he's on a Palestinian TV
network and he's explaining full-out
that the vast majority of people who
were killed were Hamas members members
of terrorist groups this is in the last
row two conversations if 62 people were
martyred 50 of them or Hamas
50 of them were come out so gay Hamas is
not hiding the ball they are not hiding
the ball their absolutely clear about
this they organized this stuff because
they wanted people shot
they organized violent protests at the
border because they want people shot
because they liked the pictures or
alternatively they were hoping they
could break the fence and people would
rush through all the people who are
saying today
why didn't Israel use rubber bullets why
didn't Israel use alternative forms of
dissuasion when it came to the border
because if they had done that then
people would have cut through the border
and you know what happened then you know
what happened if the pet if Hamas gets
through the border literally hundreds of
terrorists were waiting to rush through
the border if the border opens and you
know what that's gonna mean then it's
gonna mean that Israel has to mow down
hundreds of people mow them down because
once they get into Israel you know
they're gonna do they're gonna go to any
Israeli settlement they can find any
place that Israelis live any place the
Jews live and they're going to murder
them in their beds
that's what Hamas does and yet it's
Israel that's the problem here it's
Israel that's a serious issue here you
see the Democrats making this case it's
just astonishing Bernie Sanders he
blames President Trump for all of us now
come us which again has been doing this
sort of thing since Hamas was conceived
Hamas has been leading riots and
violence and murder and kidnapping of
Israeli soldiers and civilians for
decades at this point and they've
certainly been doing it since 2006 when
they took over the Gaza Strip but Bernie
Sanders is gonna blame President Trump
for all of this even though Trump is as
it turns out relatively new on the scene
here's Bernie Sanders in ignorance
anti-israel basher doing this routine
and I fear that we are gonna get sucked
into a Sunni Shia Saudi Arabia Iran war
which could be never-ending never-ending
I think we're looking at an Orwellian
nightmare of never ending war and we've
got to do everything we can to prevent
that just justice in just insane just
insane it we're in and we're fueling
we're fueling Trump Republicans
Americans were fueling an Orwellian war
between Shia and Sunni dude the Shia
Sunni war has been going on for
legitimately a thousand years and as for
the notion that Shia Sunni war now is
being promulgated by President Trump no
it was promulgated by President Obama
who decided to strengthen Iran and it's
irani and money that's being put in the
pockets of camasta rurus today it's
irani and money that is being used to
pay people to get shot by Israelis this
is uncontroversial but Democrats
have a particular perspective on the
world that is completely a factual and
they continue to push that perspective
as well Whoopi Goldberg doing this
routine - well you know the u.s. lost
credibility by putting our embassy in
Jerusalem
oh you mean as opposed to when we lost
credibility by having a hundred and
fifty billion dollars to the Iranian
government a terrorist government Whoopi
Goldberg Middle East expert explain it
what we I don't think that any one side
should have done this I don't think we
should have done this at all and now
we've lost our I feel lost a bit of
credibility because the Palestinians
also feel that that's their land -
they've you know they've lived their
life has been there you know that's this
their blood also okay this is incorrect
the idea that the United States was ever
supposed to be an honest broker between
a liberal democracy in the Middle East
and a terror States in the Gaza Strip
and the Palestinian Authority is
patently insane well good for the Trump
administration the Trump administration
has stood tall here nikki Haley at the
UN doing what needed to be done
yesterday of course there was a UN
Security Council resolution brought
against Israel because of course there
was because the UN Security Council is a
heaping pile of flaming garbage the UN
itself should be torn down and we should
salt the ruins I mean the United Nations
is just a horrific institution a
horrible institution filled with evil
nations who get an equal say in the
supposed rules of international law it's
an absurd institution there's no
rationale for having an institution with
Saudi Arabia and Afghanistan on their
Human Rights Council it's just it's just
bizarre and weird anyway nikki Haley is
there and the UN has basically become a
staging ground for and for Democrats
it's a way for them to go there and rip
on the United States as Barack Obama was
fond of doing and for Republicans it's a
way for Republicans to go there and rip
on the the international body itself
there is nikki Haley yesterday defending
Israel's actions in the Gaza Strip which
of course you should be doing nikki
Haley again my spirit she is my spirit
animal at the UN at the UN nikki Haley
is my spirit animal here she is I asked
my colleagues here in the Security
Council who among us would accept this
type of activity on your border no one
would no country in this chamber would
act with more restraint then Israel has
in fact the records of several countries
here today suggests they would be much
less restrained of course all of this is
true whether they're 45 Palestinians who
were killed in Syria in April you heard
about any of that you hear about a word
about that note because it wasn't Jews
who are doing the shooting as long as it
is Jews who are defending themselves
then suddenly the world media is up and
armed someone explain a little while why
the media react this way with regard to
Israel as opposed to reacting when other
nations kill people wholesale as opposed
to Israel which engaged in
extraordinarily targeted killings
amazing again the New York Times was
suggesting indiscriminate killing by
Israel 50 of the 62 people who were
killed were actual members of Hamas we
know at least another three or member
visit of Islamic Jihad so that means
that 53 out of the 62 killed were active
members of terrorist organizations and
they're calling that indiscriminate
they're calling that indiscriminate hey
Bibi Netanyahu is exactly right here the
Prime Minister of Israel says listen
there's only one group of people who are
responsible for what's happening right
now and it is the folks at Hamas they're
pushing civilians women children into
the line of fire with the view of
getting casualties we try to minimize
casualties they're trying to incur
casualties in order to in order to put
pressure on Israel which is horrible and
what is the proof of this the proof of
this is that Hamas has repeatedly
historically
continuously hid behind civilians in the
middle of war there was a report from
The Washington Post in the middle of the
2014 Gaza war that Hamas was hiding
weapons in schools in schools because
they knew that if Israel were to bomb
the schools then the international
community would blame the Israel for the
hiding behind civilians this is not new
this is not new and again they are not
hiding the ball here I'm going to show
you some of the things than people in
the media been saying about this it's
just astonishing in just a second first
I want to say thanks to our new sponsors
over at dinotrap so dynatrap these are
the people who ensure that your house is
not filled with bugs summertime is
officially upon us and the only thing
more irritating than the Democrats or
the liberal or the left-leaning media
are the Flies mosquitoes and other
insects invading your home and you know
the honestly I'm not even sure that that
even the Flies and mosquitoes are quite
as annoying is the left media at this
point but you don't want either of those
things in your home and that's why you
need die in the trap so dynatrap is the
leading manufacturer of outdoor mosquito
and insect traps and they've come out
with the indoor dynatrap fly light it
looks like a subtle nightlight that
plugs into any in
or outlet the fly light works day and
night to attract and trap flies
mosquitoes other pesky insects and it
definitely worked so if you have you
want to open the window because a nice
night out but you're afraid that the
house is gonna be invaded with bugs well
this is why you need the dynatrap fly
light we've been using the dynatrap fly
light at our house because we do have a
bit of a bug problem and it really has
cleaned everything up it's really
terrific time the trap has other
products as well for outside trust me
there's nothing more embarrassing and
gross looking than hanging up an
old-school flypaper in your home it
makes it look like you live in a slum
plus you never know what kind of
bacteria flies are spreading which is
why you need dynatrap go to Dyn a tra P
comm it's dynatrap comm and enter the
promo code a ly wire and get 15% off any
of their products again that's 15% off
any of their products so go check it out
right now dynatrap comm enter that promo
code daily wire dynatrap is the safe
silent simple solution to household
insect control it is definitely
worthwhile getting keeping your house
and bug free okay so speaking of the
insanity of the media there there are
legitimately members of the media today
who are saying that because israel did
not lose any soldiers because there are
no Jews who are killed in this
confrontation with terrorists and
rioters at the border which is the whole
purpose of having a border the whole
purpose having a barbed wire borders so
that you do not have to have your own
soldiers killed attempting to kill
terrorists because Israel killed 62
people and Noah's Raley's were killed
there legitimately people saying today
that this is a massacre and Israel has
lost the moral high ground yeah I'm not
kidding they are saying that more Jews
should have died if Israel wanted to
show parody they should have apparently
just dropped a bunch of Jews naked into
the middle of the Gaza Strip and I have
a few of them torn apart limb from limb
as has actually happened to an Israeli
soldier in in Ramallah about 15 years
ago did you just go ahead and do that
and then everything will be fine then
well then we'll acknowledge that there's
moral parity but because Israel killed
more Palestinians and Israel did not die
there were no Israelis who died this
means there was no moral parity hey
Damon linker from the weak whose work
sometimes I like I mean this is crazy he
tweeted out when people on both sides
died it's a battle when people on only
one side die it's a massacre
even when Jews do it dude
go F yourself I mean are you kidding me
so if somebody attacks me on the street
and I pull out my gun and I shoot them
you know what the score is the score is
no 1 0 was it was it self-defense turns
out it was
because self-defense is not based on the
amount of damage that the person does to
me it is not based on how many of my
children the person kills before I shoot
them my whole goal is to prevent the
death of me or my children or my family
members or my friends that's what's
going on in Israel because if these
invaders cross the border they are not
there to run in and drop a job
application at the local Spyros that's
not their goal they're not trying to
break through the border because they
are desperate to go to an Israeli
McDonald's that's not what's happening
here what's happening here is very
simple people are trying to cross the
border to commit acts of terror they're
openly admitting us it's not just damon
linker tweeting out this insanity
there's Haroon Moghul at nbcnews.com who
for some reason was solicited to write a
piece and he writes quote a hugely
disproportionate number of palestinians
died while few if any Israelis ever do
in this case zero still Israel claims it
is defending itself again what in the
living hell are you talking about dude
right of course of course Israel is
losing less people in the Palestinians
you know why because they actually built
a state with an active military that is
capable of protecting its citizens as
opposed to the mosque which is a
tyrannical military dictatorship but
we're supposed to believe that Israel
lost moral legitimacy because it didn't
kill more of its own Jews
the whole reason Israel was established
in the first place is to protect Jews
from having to be killed Jews were sick
after 2,000 years of being killed unmask
it turns out they were sick of earning
the moral high ground through their ago
their corpses being spread on fields
everywhere and so they decided hey you
know it might be good let's pick up some
guns and create a state they did and now
when the Jews defend themselves in well
you know if more Jews were to die then
that would definitely be more
even-handed you know what I'm not gonna
sacrifice any of my family members
you're not gonna sacrifice any of your
family members if anybody said this
about American soldiers everybody would
understand how disgusting and evil is's
well if more American soldiers were to
be killed surely that would establish a
moral parity go really go to hell go to
hell I mean what what absolute a
nonsensical garbage okay meanwhile the
real question to be asked here is why
are the media doing this again
the ball is not being hidden everything
is transparent everything is out front
everything is absolutely 100% clear you
can see what Camus is doing there are
pictures of it there are tapes of it
they're talking about it openly to
pretend that this is not happening is to
be willfully blind and yet members of
the media are being willfully blind
you've got idiots like
goldberg over at the new york times who
legitimately is a dumb human being and
she wrote quote on monday Ivanka Trump
Jared Kushner and other leading lights
of the trumpets right gathered in Israel
to celebrate the relocation of the
American Embassy to Jerusalem adjustor
widely seen as a slap in the face
to Palestinians who envisioned East
Jerusalem as their future capital first
of all if the Palestinians wanted to cut
a deal and make me streusel in their
future capital guess where the United
States would put their Palestinian
embassy in East Jerusalem you told and
then she says the event was grotesque it
was a consummation of the cynical
alliance between hawkish Jews and
Zionists evangelicals who believe the
return of Jews to Israel will usher in
the apocalypse and the return of Christ
after which Jews who don't convert will
burn forever has this person ever met a
Christian a Michele globert she's
writing this in the pages of the most
prestigious newspaper in America has she
ever met a person who believes in the
Jesus has she ever met a person who goes
to church and Michelle Goldberg I'm not
sure has ever met an evangelical
Christian if she believes that all
evangelical Christians are just trying
to reestablish Jerusalem is the Israeli
capital so that Jesus will make his
grand reappearance and then they'll all
forcibly convert the Jews or the Jews
will won't won't be raptured or somesuch
and some such that it like this is so
ignorant can I talk to thousands of
evangelicals thousands of them not just
daily on the show I mean in person I
talked to thousands of evangelical
Christians across the country I have not
heard this used as an excuse for backing
Israel by one of them not one ok this is
not typical that this is the sort of
millennialist view of Christian support
of Israel this is a straw man that is
put up by folks on the left because the
vast majority of evangelicals do not
believe that this is why they are
supporting Israel they believe they're
supporting Israel because Israel is a
moral power in the region because Israel
has a historical and religious right to
be there and because Israel is the root
of the Western civilized tree that is
why not because of any of this
revelations type stuff hey but the media
are pushing Hamas is propaganda they're
pushing Hamas is propaganda why so
there's a couple reasons why the media
are pushing Hamas is propaganda first
members of the Western media believe
wrongly that everyone thinks the same
things about human rights and individual
freedom they think this so they have
this weird bizarre perspective that
everyone secretly deep down in the
cockles of their heart wants to live in
San Francisco but that's that's the kind
of life they want to live that if you
are a pal
in a Muslim Palestinian who believes
that the al-aqsa mosque is a holy holy
place and that the Jews are occupiers
from the river to the sea that if you
believe that really you don't believe
that really what you really believe is
that there should be gay rights and
everybody shouldn't have kids they
should have puppies and that every and
that the sexual revolution was awesome
that's that's what everyone's seriously
believes like deep down but these
Palestinians don't believe it because of
the system because of the hierarchy
because of oppression and repression and
when they sacrifice children by putting
them out at the front lines and when
they hide behind those children as
terrorists the reason they're doing this
is out of desperation so assumption
number one is the Palestinians actually
want the same thing so that Westerners
do unmask hey this is not true there are
some Palestinians who certainly want
those things but the vast majority of
Palestinians in the Gaza Strip voted for
Hamas in 2006 and polls show the vast
majority of them are supportive of Hamas
now okay so that's paternalistic view
number one paternalistic view number two
is that Palestinians are not actively
pursuing Western definitions of freedom
but that's not because they don't
believe in Western definitions of
freedom no cuz everyone believes in
Western definitions of freedom they
don't believe in Western definitions of
freedom and they don't pursue Western
definitions of freedom because they are
so oppressed and because they are angry
and humiliated and that's why if we just
got rid of the anger and humiliation
then the Palestinian Authority Hamas all
these people would be thrown out in
favor of the Labor Party in Britain
that's what would happen this is so
paternalistic it is so ignorant of
realities on the ground it is almost
beyond words
Sarab Amari writes a commentary is
exactly right Palestinian Arabs are
human beings which means they're
possessed of freewill agency and the
natural capacity to reason like any
other people this basic incontestable
anthropological reality needs to be
frequently restated today since our
media and foreign policy establishment
have apparently concluded the opposite
they're desperate people all over the
world who never translate their
frustration into suicide bombings
stone-throwing border rushing and days
of Rage it does the Palestinians no good
to treat them as children entitled to
tantrums as permanent Ward's of the
international community or worse as wild
men bereft of reason then again such
high-handed pity isn't really about
helping the Palestinians so much as it
is about flattering than Western friends
okay so in just a second I want to
explain why it seems the press has such
an empathy to Israel it is connected
with the press is antipathy for
president Trump their antipathy for
brexit their antipathy for nationalism
more generally I'll explain first I want
to say thanks to our sponsor is over at
upsides
so if you are an astronaut you would
need Mission Control you would need
somebody on the ground telling you that
they were getting things taken care of
this is what most people are looking for
in life are people who are out there to
help them to ensure they get where they
need to go when they need to get there
well this is what upside is for they are
your Mission Control they're looking out
for you every step of the way they are
handling any problem that might pop up
they have a team of specialists that
work 24/7 to make sure your flight hotel
and car rental all go off without a
hitch
I can't tell you the number of times
that I have traveled and I have used
another website to travel and it turns
out that there's some problem in the
process and then you go to the counter
and they're like well you know you
booked through one of these other
websites and we can't help you tough
tough news and you trying to call up the
website and there's nobody there to help
you up side is the opposite up side is
going to help you they monitor your trip
around the clock they proactively keep
you posted on everything from if it's
gonna rain to alternative return flights
home in case you want to squeeze in
another meeting
you're not gonna experience this level
of service anywhere else once you've
experienced that concierge service from
up side you're not going to want to use
any other travel website for easy
booking competitive prices in a team
that always has your back go to upside
calm and for a limited time when you
booked your first business trip path
upside you get a minimum $100 amazon.com
gift card which is pretty awesome go to
up side comm slash been booked your
first business trip
up side comm slash been use that slash
pin you get $100 amazon.com gift card
when you book your first trip $600
minimum purchase required while supplies
last see the site for complete details
again that's upside calm slash Bend
check it out it's pretty awesome okay so
why is it that the Western media are so
why do they have such antipathy for
Israel why Israel so the easy answer is
because they're not fond of the udin
okay and maybe there's some truth to
that but I would venture to say that
most of the people who are anti-israel
don't consider themselves anti-semitic
they'll tell you they have it they have
Jewish friends many of them are Jewish
so why is it that there's this antipathy
for Israel it goes to something deeper
it goes to something deeper and that is
there has been a shift in the Western
mentality with regard to the
nation-state so there's been a lot of
talk lately about the differences
between nationalism and patriotism well
I believe that I'm a more patriotic guy
than nationalistic guy meaning I'm not a
blood in the soil nationalists who
believes that just because I was born
here America is great now I think
America is great because we share a
common heritage a common hold culture a
common set of values but I do believe
that the nation-state is a better way to
organize the world than is an
international utopian globe
government I just don't think that's
gonna work I think it's no it's never
worked I think an attempt to spread
Empire has usually failed the
nation-state is a better solution to
people's aspirations so long as the
nation state is promulgating good values
because having a group of people who
share a certain tribal affinity thanks
to culture and values and also share a
value system that is worth upholding
this has been the basis of Western
civilization for a very long time
particularly since the Protestant
Reformation the Peace of Westphalia in
which the idea of sort of a Catholic
hegemony over the Western world was
shattered in favor of this idea that if
you are a nation you deserve
self-determination so long as you
fulfilled certain basic moral precepts
Yoram hezonia of the Herzl Institute has
written about this his great new book
that is out and I believe in September
called the virtue of nationalism totally
worth the read and really interesting as
he points out nationalism was
responsible for the rise of France in
the rise of Britain as well as the rise
of Germany now after World War Two
there's a real push against nationalism
right after World War one there was a
push in favor of nationalism there was a
push in favor of the idea of
self-determination of people's said they
wouldn't be under the thumb of for
example a German Empire or Russian
Empire but after World War two
after the Nazis there's a push against
nationalism the idea was that German
nationalism had led to World War two in
reality it was German imperialism that
led to World War two it was Germany
attempting to expand its borders outward
not Germany saying hey we just want to
sit here within our own borders and not
bother anybody
right that's nationalism but imperialism
is the idea that you're going to take
your nation and spread it out globally
not that you're going to spread your
values where possible among Allied
nations but that you are legitimately
going to take over other nations and
make them Germany right and that was the
German ideal during World War Two under
the Nazis this is the idea of a Reich
there's this Third Reich okay so what
happened is that after World War Two
there was a rejection of nationalism
wholesale Yoram hezonia rights and I
think he's correct today many in the
West have come to regard an intense
personal loyalty to the neh to the
national state and it's right to chart
an independent course as something not
only unnecessary but morally suspect
they no longer see national loyalties
and traditions as necessarily providing
a sound basis for determining laws we
live by for regulating the economy or
making decisions about defense and
security for establishing public norms
concerning religion or education and for
deciding who gets to live in what part
of the world the idea here is why not a
world government why not be a real
well if it's so great why not just
spread those rules out for everyone the
UN can rule all of us why not reject in
this case Israel sovereignty in favor of
an internationalized Jerusalem why not
say there needed to be no Jewish state
instead Jews should just become citizens
of the world because we all should be
citizens of the world the answer is
obvious nations still exist because
human beings do not operate this way
human beings do have tribal affinity
human beings do look for a collective
that shares their values to be a part of
and that collective is not going to be
global it isn't because people do not
share enough values for those
collectives to be global the entire
globe does not think like the Editorial
Board of the New York Times Israel has
to exist because the rest of the world
doesn't think like the Editorial Board
of the New York Times and by the way if
the rest of the world did think like the
Editorial Board of the New York Times
Israel would still have to exist because
the New York Times is very much in favor
of apparently a Palestinian terrorism
viacom oz Israel has a right to exist
and to defend itself the same people who
oppose Israel opposed brexit and they
think the president from saying things
like make America great again is
inherently evil because they think
nationalism is the problem you know
moving in in the aftermath of the Hana
rent's ideology about how nationalism
was the great curse on humanity which
really is not true tremendous tremendous
violence has happened between
nation-states no doubt but usually that
violence happening between nation-states
is because of imperial ambitions that
extend beyond the nation-state in any
case the media continued Amira Hamas is
preferred line and that is going to get
more Palestinians killed mark levin said
yesterday that the the palestinians are
going to the palestinians are going to
die because of what media is doing the
media has blood on its hands this is
absolutely true when the media say that
hamas wins every time a palestinian is
killed what do you think Hamas is going
to do they're gonna put babies on the
front line so put women on the front
lines they can put children on the front
lines and then they're going to claim
that Israel is evil and Israel is
terrible it's the same thing terrorist
groups try to do with the United States
terrorist groups have been doing this
for legitimately decades it's the reason
why the Geneva Conventions were written
in the first place okay the reason that
the Geneva Conventions were created in
the first place was specifically to
convince people to stop acting as
terrorists hiding among civilian
populations the idea was if you dressed
in a uniform and he went out away from
the the civilian population then you
were accorded certain additional rights
whereas if you hid among civilians then
those rights went away that was a good
thing we're obscure
now because we are stupid here in the
West and we think that everybody has the
same aspirations that we do this
obviously is not true okay I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over at policy
genius so you need life insurance okay
look you're gonna die we're all gonna
die okay sorry to break it to you I know
it's a downer but what do you do you
shouldn't leave your family without any
money and that's why you need life
insurance 80% of people think life
insurance costs double what it actually
cost not only that almost a hundred
percent of people think buying life
insurance is a pain in the neck the
truth is a healthy 35 year old can get
half a million bucks in coverage for
less than 30 bucks a month and getting
life insurance does not have to be
complicated because there's policy
genius policy genius is the easy way to
compare life insurance online in just
five minutes you can compare quotes from
the top insurers to find the best policy
for you policy genius has helped over 4
million people shop for insurance placed
over 20 billion dollars in coverage and
they don't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
and renter's insurance and health
insurance if you care about it they can
cover it they make it super super easy
you're online right now probably
listening to the show so go to policy
genius while you're sitting there and
get it done policy genius com it's the
easy way to compare top insurers and
find the best policy for you again save
time save money save hassle and it's
free there's no excuse for leaving your
family without money if you die policy
genius.com makes sure you won't go to
policy genius.com
go check it out right now ok so in other
foreign policy news president Trump is
apparently being jerked around by the
North Koreans we'll talk about that in
just a second first you're gonna have to
go over to daily wire.com and subscribe
so for $9.99 a month you get the rest of
this show live there are some tools in
show live the rest of Clavin show live
and special benefits we are now doing
live events and as you can see because
we're doing live events in places like
Dallas and Phoenix because we are doing
those things if you are a member if you
have membership through daily wire calm
this means you get first crack at the
VIP tickets it means you get first crack
at the seats right now you can buy
tickets in Dallas in Phoenix but only if
you remember ok you're gonna if you're
not a member you have to wait for
another day and a half and so when you
get that membership you also get the
annual membership you get this leftist
year's hot or cold mug which apparently
is just being filled on a routine basis
this week by leftist who don't know the
first thing about foreign policy but
also we'd appreciate it if you over to
Apple News and check out daily wire over
at Apple News where you can get our all
of the stuff that we are breaking which
we are breaking news on a constant basis
its daily wires to check that out if you
wanna listen later to the show for free
go over to YouTube subscribe please go
over to over to iTunes and subscribe and
please leave us a review to always
we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so now the latest with regards to
North Korea so North Korea is
threatening to pull out of this big this
big summit that they were going to have
with President Trump this is always the
danger of President Trump accepting the
idea of going to a summit in the first
place in doing so very publicly as
opposed to sort of just keeping it on
the down-low and then spring it on ever
by the way next week I'm meeting with
the North Koreans the North Koreans are
now trying to convince the United States
to stop military drills by withdrawing
the possibility of the meeting I was
always very skeptical of this meeting
you can go back and listen to the show I
was very skeptical of the idea anything
good was gonna come from this meeting I
was very skeptical of the idea that
North Korea is going to give up its
nuclear weapons particularly because
North Korea knowing that the United
States would topple them if they didn't
have nuclear weapons has an interest in
pursuing nuclear weapons full-scale at
this point well according to the Daily
Mail North Korea's government says it is
considering calling off a planned
nuclear summit between Kim jong-un and
president Donald Trump Kim's regime said
through state-run news agency KCNA that
ongoing max Thunder joint military
exercises between the u.s. and South
Korea are actually a rehearsal for
invasion of the North KCNA said quote
the United States will also have to
undertake careful deliberations about
the fate of the plan North Korea u.s.
summit in light of this provocative
military ruckus jointly conducted with
the South Korean authorities first of
all well done on them for using the word
ruckus in a sentence but beyond that and
this is this is obviously a ploy to get
all of the Trump administration to back
off of the military exercise I'll
explain more in just a second first the
North Koreans are trying to pull back
obviously from the summit in an attempt
to get concessions from the Trump
administration now Trump shouldn't do it
the polarity has been reversed hey used
to be the North Koreans were seeking
some sort of summit with Trump now once
Trump has said yes he's invested in the
idea of a summit this happens with every
president it happened with Obama too
once Obama was invested in the idea of a
rapprochement with Iran then he was
invested in pretending that Iran was
actually doing the right thing
well now the Trump administration is
sort of getting sucked into the cycle as
well because now president Trump
parently the White House has said that
they are going to scale down the this
particular exercise so according to you
UPI joint exercises between the United
States and South Korea will move forward
but the b-52 strategic bomber and eight
f-22 Raptors will
not be deployed during drills the
decision to downscale the drills was
reached between US forces Korea
commander Vincent Brooks and South
Korean Defense Minister song you young
mu Wednesday after North Korea
criticized the joint exercise max
Thunder being held in the south
according to News one so the criticism
of the United States and South Korea
came as a surprise to the South Korean
military the United States should not
have done this we should not have scaled
back the military exercise we should
have told the South Koreans were not
willing to scale back to military
exercise no concessions to a
nuclear-armed North Korea no concession
none the United States is not in a
position to be making concessions to
probably the worst state on earth a
giant gulag State there is no excuse for
this it is it is bad policy as good as
the Trump administration has been on
Middle Eastern policy when it comes to
North Korean policy making concessions
to the North Koreans or making
concessions to the Chinese as Trump did
over the weekend none of that is useful
stuff you can't get invested in trying
to uphold the credibility of a regime
that should have no credibility in the
first place okay in other breaking news
apparently there's a bunch of documents
that have now come out from the
interviews by by Congress with Donald
Trump jr. and it turns out that Donald
Trump jr. may or may not have spoken to
Donald Trump senior after meeting with
Russian lawyers at Trump Tower in June
2016 you'll recall the Donald Trump jr.
met with a Russian lawyer named the
vessel Mnet's kaya
who he had been told was going to give
him material on Hillary Clinton and that
material never materialized but the
question was whether he had told
President Trump about it well now what
the call logs show is that in the middle
of that meeting he talked with vessel
Matt Skye apparently and then there was
an a call to an unnamed number an
untraceable number and then it was like
four minutes long and Trump jr. says
that he does not know exactly who is on
the other end of that phone he doesn't
remember
I find this relatively unlikely I would
not be surprised at all if president
from knew about the Trump Tower meeting
this however does not prove collusion in
order to prove collusion you have to
prove not only that the Trump
administration was willing to collude
and that they were willing to talk with
the Russian government about going after
Hillary Clinton but that they did in
fact collude the material Swit
transferred hands that there was actual
there is actual coordination between the
Russian government and the Trump
campaign none of that has been proved to
any significant extent we've known this
since last year it is a big deal okay I
don't want to pretend it's not a big
deal
that Donald Trump jr. and top members of
the term
campaign were meeting with emissaries
from the Russian government to get dirt
on Hillary Clinton obviously that is a
problem okay but if none of the material
changed hands there's no active
collusion and there's no crime so intent
does not actually constitute the crime
in this particular case plus Donald
Trump jr. it's gonna be very hard to
catch him criminally because he did what
any lawyer would advise Donald Trump jr.
to do here he said I don't remember I
don't remember who I was talking to I
don't remember what happened at this
meeting but he had a sudden bout of
amnesia not uncommon in the legal world
it makes a fair bit of sense legally I
think that the left is is going a little
bit crazy over all of this the left is
suggesting that this is finally the
death knell for Trump it's not going to
happen and this is one of the big
problems that the left has right now if
you look at the polls the generic ballot
the generic ballot right now is not that
great for Democrats they're up by on an
average 5.2 percent okay that is
significantly down from the 8 to 10
percent that it was just a couple of
months ago part of the reason for that
is because Democrats have been
proclaiming from the tops of hills for
literally two years now that there was
going to be some deus ex machina that
somebody was going to come in from the
outside and depose from robert muller
was gonna come in and save america from
the scourge of Trump or Donald Trump jr.
was gonna come forward with evidence and
that would save America from the scourge
of Trump okay none of this is going to
happen Trump is going to remain in
office for his entire tenure he's going
to be there for at least four years and
maybe eight and and the sooner Democrats
get used to that idea the sooner they
can start fighting him smart but they're
not fighting him smart instead they're
moving far to the far to the left so
it's kind of interesting there's a case
to be made that Barack Obama drove the
right so nuts that they began nominating
terrible cans and it's just because they
were the most extreme candidates in
primaries well Donald Trump has driven
the left so nuts his victory has driven
the left so out of their minds that they
are now nominating the most extreme
candidates that they can find so they
are attempting to nominate candidates
like this one here's an ad that was run
by a Democrat you in which he
legitimately says F V NRA in the middle
of the ad the NRA they're pro-gun
policies have resulted in dead children
dead mothers and dead fathers I'm Pat
Davis and I approve this message because
if Congress won't change our gun laws
we're changing Congress so Pat Davis was
running for the Democratic nomination in
New Mexico's first district and he says
F the NRA and that's his actual ad again
guys probably more popular than the main
stir
members of the Democratic coalition
which is not supremely surprising
because the Democratic coalition doesn't
have a lot to say on a lot of major
issues there's an article in The
Washington Post specifically today about
the fact that the the Democratic
coalition seems to be nominating the
most extreme possible human beings which
is which is obviously mean last night
there were two socialists who won in
races in Pennsylvania socialists open
socialists the Democratic Party is is
polarizing largely in response to what
has happened with President Trump so
president Trump's victory has made the
left crazy it's making them crazy in the
same way that there's a case to be made
that the right started nominating bad
candidates because they were so driven
nuts by President Obama and dominance to
the left
well now the left is seeing that in
Reverse there's and there's an article
by James Holman over at the Washington
Post today called the far left is
winning the Democratic civil war the
success of very liberal candidates in
primaries across four states is causing
a new bout of heartburn among party
strategists in Washington who worry
about unelectable activists forwarding
their drive for the House Majority I
remember when these articles were being
written about folks from the right like
five minutes ago now it's being written
about folks from the left and that's
because folks from the left legitimately
legitimately have have I think reacted a
president Trump with the most extreme
possible rhetoric that's what's going to
get them elected they know it but it's
not gonna go get them elected in in
general elections it works in primaries
doesn't work in generals okay so
meanwhile it turns out that the TV
industry has decided that it is deeply
imperative to revive every show that has
ever been on TV for any amount of time
so they've already revived Roseanne and
now they apparently reviving Murphy
Brown so CBS executives revealed to
reporters on Wednesday morning the
return of the politically minded
nineteen nineties year a comedy series
but it will have a new setting so in the
original Candice Bergen z-- Murphy Brown
anchor and a primetime news magazine you
recall that Candice Brown made a lot of
headlines at the time because Candice
Brown got she her character Murphy Brown
rather got pregnant out of wedlock and
then had the baby and when Dan Quayle
suggested that this might not be a good
influence on people the entire left went
insane how dare he suggest that culture
is in any way connected to politics then
when Joe Biden said without Will and
Grace that wouldn't be gay marriage
everybody yeah that's true so it turns
out the culture does have an impact on
politics but in any case now
Murphy Brown is going to be hosting a
show called Murphy in the morning her
biggest competitor will be her own son
who is hosting his own conservative
Morning News show this is just what we
need we need a really politicized show I
think I think we need more pop culture
that that demonstrates full scale the
gap between left and right I think
that's really gonna be good for the
country
when executives were asked if the set up
was supposed to mirror Morning Joe
versus Fox & Friends
they said yes so CBS entered him and
President Kelley call said we fully
expect a lot of people are going to come
to Murphy Brown we felt this could be a
great piece to make this block the
strongest on TV so apparently they have
a combination of new and old cast
members it's gonna go in CBS's comedy
block on Thursdays at 9:30 p.m. the
moving political is is only smart if
you're actually moving along with the
times
I highly doubt I really doubt that
Murphy Brown is is suddenly going to be
the big hit the way that Roseanne was
when it first broke in because we've
seen shows from Hollywood before in
which the right is castigated as
terrible and evil and ignorant and
bigoted and in fact I think Roseanne has
moved in that direction I mean this has
been one of the problems with Rosen's
ratings it started off like a house
afire because there are a lot of Trump
supporters said wow people who aren't
openly disrespecting me and then it
turns out that Roseanne is what rosy on
always was which is a socially left show
which is promulgating particular
messages that a lot of Trump supporters
don't believe in and so people stopped
watching the show once it turned into
another leftist soap opera with a few
laughs thrown in people weren't as
interested in it but this is the way
that Hollywood works right Hollywood can
never grant a fully fully formed
conservative character unless they are
cast as a sort of mentorship character
who's fuddy-duddy and old and kind of
out of it like Ron Swanson or like Alec
Baldwin's character in Jack Donaghy in
in 30 rock if you're that kind of
character they'll cast you but what's
hilarious about that is that as soon as
those characters appear on TV they
immediately become the most popular
characters on the show conservative
characters are actually deeply popular
on television because conservative
characters make for good comedy when you
put a bunch of lefties with their
hoity-toity notions about the world in
front of conservatives who are sitting
there doing the facts don't care about
your feelings routine which really was
Ron Swanson's routine in Parks and Rec
and Jack Donaghy's routine in 30 rock
when you do that people resonate to him
they're not going to resonate nearly as
much - why don't you come here and we'll
lecture you come here and we will
lecture you about the
right thing to do now speaking of bias
in the media John Oliver did a full on
defense of venezuelan venezuelan social
as an independent as well and socialism
so much as he defended socialism from
venezuela x' failures so here is john
oliver on his show the other night
trying to say that venezuela is not real
socialism real socialism is the
countries that I like and that aren't
really socialist Venezuela is not
socialist because he Venezuela lost
because it was mismanaged not because
it's socialist here's John Oliver making
that idiotic case but what is happening
in Venezuela is not just extremely
important it is absolutely worth paying
attention to because this is not just a
story about socialism there are plenty
of socialist countries that look nothing
like Venezuela it's a story about epic
mismanagement so epic that a nation of
31 million people with the largest oil
reserves in the world have been forced
to resort to some pretty creative forms
of protein well Courtney according to
John Oliver there's apparently no
connection between a giant centralized
government including nationalization of
resources and government mismanagement
none incredible incredible you know
people will like to cite Norway in this
context well or way as a large national
I sector right and when they own large
pieces of stock in companies they allow
those companies to function like private
entities in the market in fact if they
don't meet certain profit margins then
they change that then they change the
the staff at those particular companies
so it's always funny how Democrats
people on the Left people like John
Oliver like to pick and choose among the
socialist countries they like the ones
they like happened not to be
particularly socialist the ones that are
most socialist including centralization
of resources and top-down government
centralization of management power those
are the ones that that they're just
failing cuz I mentioned management no
one understands why they were mismanaged
they just sort of work weird how that
works if only socialism or really tried
you know really tried then things would
go well is that were socialism if it
fails it's only socialism is if it
succeeds
which means real socialism has never
been tried because real socialism has
never actually succeeded okay time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so this may be the most
beautiful piece ever written this is a
piece by Robert Schumann called vid Munk
and it was it is in an area that was
translated
transferred over to pianos rewritten for
piano by Franz Liszt who is a
contemporary of Robert Schumann it's
just a gorgeous piece Schumann's life is
such a tragedy he had a bunch of kids
with his wife Clara Schumann who was a
concert pianist in her
right entry toured around Europe and
they were very close with Brahms like he
actually called Brahms the next coming
of Beethoven basically which is a pretty
heavy burden to put on Brahms promising
him very close to the family and then
Schumann became severely mentally ill
here she died in a sanatorium because he
was deeply mentally ill and Brahms fell
in love sort of with Clara as all of
this was happening it's really a really
sad story
in any case this piece of music by
Robert Schumann is just fantastic this
is Arthur Rubinstein one of the great
pianists who ever lived
playing the the Schumann's vid Mon
[Music]
it's just a fantastic piece it's not
particularly long it's about four or
five minutes long I can go check it out
over at YouTube they have a version of
it it's it's just a beautiful beautiful
piece so go check that out okay time for
a thing that I hate
so yesterday Tom Wolfe passed away Tom
Wolfe was one of the great a nonfiction
journalists of the 20th century I would
say that he was the best nonfiction
journalist of last half of the 20th
century first half you'd have to say was
George Orwell second half you could
easily say was Tom Wolfe some of his
journalism is just phenomenally died at
the age of 87 and his if you've never
read radical chic and mounting the flak
catchers these are two of his finest
essays he wrote a piece called radical
chic it is in in 1966 and it was about
Leonard Bernstein who is the who is the
conductor and head of the New York
Philharmonic and who was a far left guy
like really far left and his wife
Felicia who decided they were going to
have the Black Panthers to their
apartment and the piece is called
radical chic and I want to read you a
little section of it just to show you
how amazing these like legitimately how
amazing Tom Wolf's writing was Tom Wolfe
was able to go into places that no one
would have allowed him in because he was
considered a hunter s Thompson type why
this weird style of writing and he was
kind of kooky right he wore white suits
and all this so he couldn't really been
conservative it turns out Tom Wolfe was
a deeply conservative dude and Tom
Wolf's writing is deeply conservative if
you've never had bonfire of the vanities
the first half a bonfire of the vanities
is some of the best novel writing ever
and some of the best political
commentary ever second half falls apart
a little bit but the first half of
bonfire of the vanities is just great I
think I've read every novel he ever
wrote and most of his nonfiction and I'm
very sad that I never got to meet it
because I was big admirer
this is a section from radical chic this
is Tom Wolfe writing about all of these
far left is having the Black Panthers
over the Black Panthers who are
acknowledging openly but they want to
kill pigs and murder white people and
all of these radical left people sitting
there in their swanky penthouse
apartment in New York City nodding at
them and thinking that they've done
something magical by having the Black
Panthers over here's the section quote
and now in the season of radical chic
the Black Panthers that huge Panther
they're the one Felicia and this would
be leonard bernstein's wife is smiling
her tango smile at his Robert Bay who
just 41 hours ago was arrested in an
altercation with the police supposedly
over a 38 caliber revolver that someone
had in a parked car in Queens and
Northern Boulevard in one hundred and
fourth Street or some such unbelievable
place and taken to jail on the most
unusual charge called criminal
facilitation and now he is out on bail
and walking into Leonard and Felicia's
Bernstein's thirteen room penthouse
duplex on Park Avenue harassment and
hassles guns and pegs jail and bail
they're real these Panthers the very
idea of them these real revolutionaries
who put their lives on the line runs
through Lenny's duplex like a rogue
hormone everyone cast a glance or stares
or tries to smile and then size up the
house but the somewhat delicious
counterpoint tonight if you want to but
one does end up making such sweet
furtive comparisons in this season of
radical chic there's Otto Preminger in
the library and Jean Vandenheuvel in the
hall and Peter and charade douching in
the living room and frank and Amna
stanton gayle loom a Sheldon Harnick
Cynthia Phipps Burton Lane mrs. Auguste
Heckscher and scores more including
Charlotte Curtis women's news editor of
the New York Times America's foremost
chronicler of society a lean woman in
black her notebook out standing near
Felicia and big Robert Bay and talking
to charade you seen sherée tells her
I've never met a panther this is a first
for me never dreaming that within 48
hours her words will be on the desk of
the President of the United States this
is a first for me but she's not alone in
her thrill as the Black Panthers come
trucking in for in Delaney's house
Robert Bates on Cox the Panthers Field
Marshal from Oakland Henry Miller the
Harlem Panther defense captain the
Panther woman Christ if the Panthers
don't know how to get it all together as
they say the tight pants the tight black
turtlenecks the leather coats Cuban
shades afros but real afros not the ones
that have been shaped and trimmed like a
top e re hedge and sprayed until they
have a sheen like acrylic wall-to-wall
but funky natural scraggly wild these
are no Civil Rights Negroes wearing gray
suits three sizes too big no more
interminable urban league banquets in
hotel rooms where they try to alternate
blacks and whites around the table as if
they were stringing Arapahoe beads these
are real men it's just it's fantastic
writing and go check out radical chic
and mounting the flash black catchers
the best work tumble if ever did his
book the right stuff is just as terrific
it's better than the movie reel tragedy
that he's that he passed away somebody
left in an enormous and fantastic body
of work check out Tom Wolf's work if you
have not okay so we'll be back here
tomorrow with all the latest i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018